german pianist sebastian kanawa and
british south african violinist daniel
hope are both internationally known
performers so when they play together
it's bound to be special
here they're playing in the loft of a
former cowshed it's a memorable musical
experience and not just for the audience
it's levers if I hit Sue's island is I
love being here at this festival my
career really started here in Alton Hall
at the age of 12 I gave my first big
public concerts at a festival here in
Elton Hall in waters and in emkin Dorf
in Alton - Vortice in' and playing in
barns and getting back to nature what
could be nicer Nasus Mutko pools and
spas it's a lot of fun it creates a
relaxed atmosphere because you're not
sitting in a formal concert hall but in
a barn but it's still an intense
experience i know constantly at the
angulating hyatt classical music in a
cowshed it's in character for this last
we call shine Music Festival which is
known for its unusual venues close to
900 spectators fill the loft which was
renovated specially as a concert venue
the concert is being held at Alton Wolf
a historically protected estate right
next to the manor house is the cow barn
built in 1711
it was renovated in 1988 and now it's
used primarily as a concert hall here
performers almost always play to a full
house
Maur and hope have been friends for
years
the album's they've recorded together
have earned them an echo classic award
and even a Grammy nomination but they
have solo projects too
kanawa started his own Mozart Festival
in 2012 it's held in September in
Augsburg hope is currently touring to
promote his new album which is being
released this week yet the two musicians
still find time to perform together
they can on-site we've known one another
for close to 20 years I believe we've
played all over the world it's a real
joy to make music with him not only to
make music but to travel and spend time
together I'd say we're more like musical
brothers and there isn't mayor vemos de
collar shapour who devoted son but soft
xia what counts a lot is that musically
we breathe as one when we play we don't
need to talk much to discuss who planned
things they just happen all on their own
they keep CEO beauty fun aligned
like the musicians spectators also
appreciate the easygoing atmosphere here
they can experience classical music up
close here in Alton hoof the stars of
the evening don't just disappear
backstage they usually give autographs
after the show swallows fly over the
barn roof the noises filter in from
outside I'm from the country and I love
that it's awful it's wonderful that the
musicians make contact with the audience
always like their unconventional mix of
cowsheds and the classical music it was
great
George Gershwin's famous tune summertime
summer will also be drawing to a close
when the schleswig-holstein music
festival with it's moving concerts winds
up on August 31st